hello everybody my name is Colin thanks
for coming to this talk I'm excited to
be here as a web developer it's been
kind of exciting to sit in on all the
data science talks and see all the
amazing projects that everyone's been
working on it kind of gives me something
to strive for is I I can do some stuff
like this in Python so yeah i'll be
speaking about a project called open
data policing and it's it's a web app it
aggregates and displays traffic stop
data and it includes some visualizations
to help visualize and sort of step
through through that data and currently
it's it's for North Carolina but we're
planning to release it in Maryland
shortly and the talk op I'm like as just
as a high-level overview of the talk
outline the first half I'm going to
spend primarily talking about the
background of the project and some info
on the North Carolina like a data
collection law and the second half I'll
talk just about how the site works and
give you an idea about that so again my
name is khan I'm CTO cactus group
organizations turned at cactus for
python and django development done right
since 2007 our business and social
impact solutions have reached over 70
million people please stop by our booth
to learn more about cactus we're right
outside the door here come we're hiring
you can see a demo of this site and
we're also raffle raffling off a copy of
lightweight django which mark our
technical director is here and he'll be
giving a talk in the next session so you
should stop by i'm also co-captain of
code for durham which is a Code for
America Brigade here in the Triangle
this is a picture of one of our hack
nights at our office co-captain Adam
there's up in front of the room and
basically we build apps for the
community we built a variety of apps so
far including like a restaurant
sanitation score inspector the most
active one right now is an app to help
navigate the Durham public school system
and so we're just a collection of
citizens who volunteer their time to
work on
and help improve Durham that's kind of
why I started I helped start the the
group and I like the idea of just
working with community members on on
projects and so when Ian approached me
about this traffic stop project that I
was pretty excited he's an attorney with
the southern Coalition for social
justice and you know this this project
is his idea and he has and maintains the
the vision of it and so that's a caveat
I'm not a lawyer I'm not a statistician
either i'm a developer and the team here
we kind of helped like bring this this
project to the web so that it's more
accessible and so a lot of the
information that i'll touch on at the
beginning of this talk is from him and
i'll kind of summarize it at a high
level but basically ian wants to use
this traffic stop data to help promote
equity in policing and make it more
accessible both on the departmental
level and the officer level and put it
on a website and so initially the group
was was fairly small there Andy and
Dylan helped out Andy's in the crowd
there we so we were all entirely
volunteer we worked on nights and
weekends and were just kind of excited
technologists to believed in what ian
was working on and and wanted to help
folks in North Carolina and so the site
is divided into three features there's
an agency dashboard which aggregates and
displays stop searches contraband hit
rates use of force data all over time
and the the officer dashboard is the
same set of graphs is sort of narrowed
down to the officer level and then
there's a finest top feature which
allows you to basically search through
the entire data set and look for a
particular stop based on some criteria
in fact you can pull this up right now
the phase one site with North Carolina
is online it's an open data policing NC
calm feel free to navigate around a lot
of what I'll demo today we'll show a bit
of the the second phase which is
currently unreleased and cactus worked
on but the it's this site has the latest
North Carolina data that we have and so
I'll talk a little bit about that that's
right now so North Carolina was the
first state in the country to have this
type of statewide data collection law
was enacted in April of 99 so it
requires almost all police agencies to
record and track traffic stops and then
they're centrally collected at the state
level with the video J the law grew out
of a scandal that was around a drug task
force in colombo cumberland county sorry
they discovered a two to one search
disparity for narcotics officers and but
realized that the contraband hit rate
was equal among races and yet black
drivers were being searched twice as
often and so basically how they
structure the law is that any time a
police officer stops someone in North
Carolina they fill out this SBI 122 form
you can see all the fields is like 45
boxes on this forum and and some of its
digital mouths like on the in the
officers car they can fill it out on
their computer but it's also paper and
some kind of still but you can you enter
like the you know the county of stop
what was the purpose of the stop the age
the race ethnicity whether or not led to
a search lots of information is in here
yeah like an interesting point is that
the officer is kind of making the
determination here and it's probably
true that they don't always get it right
but it's the general consensus in ian's
world is to not have the officers who
just made the traffic stop to start
asking what like race and ethnicity you
are and kind of consciously injecting
race into the conversation I think as
the driver you'd probably be like why
why are you asking me that but in the
end you know officers are making these
traffic stops and I think it's a
interesting aspect to the policing
culture and like hopefully this this
data transparency will you know be
helpful to to them and and and others
and just help them be aware of what
they're stopping patterns and so the
officers give this data to their
sergeant and then that gets reported up
to the state every month and obviously
not all stops
result in searches but over time we have
a good sense of of these because we now
have 15 years of data statewide and so
and it's not just that yeah it's not a
snapshot it's a portrait of like all
stop reported stop activity in searches
statewide and another interesting note
about the statute is that as far as as
we know no one really looked at the data
for at least ten years are not really
sure why maybe because it's it's kind of
a lot of data it's not easy to kind of
just download it and open it up on like
Excel or something but Ian met a
professor at UNC when he was in law
school dr. Frank Baumgardner who he
worked with a race and justice
commission and they kind of realized
just how powerful this type of data can
be in the policy arena and so when he he
analyzed it and noticed significant
racial disparities particularly with
searches and use of force he found that
the average North Carolina officer
searches around three percent of the
people that they stopped is about one in
33 but that there's a pretty wide
variance from jurisdiction to
jurisdiction sometimes you'll find some
cities that one and six black drivers
get stopped or sometimes you'll find
individual officers who will stop like
two-thirds of all or search two-thirds
of all the drivers that they they stop
for years on end and do so with only
like a contraband hit rate in the single
digits and so bank based on Frank's
findings Ian just had this idea to make
the data more accessible like we can put
it on the website then it can sort of
help lead to promoting more equity in
policing and so I'll touch on to target
audiences public defenders and police
agencies themselves and I'll use some
examples while hopefully trying to demo
the site and so the law as written it
allows data to be used for any valid
claim or defense and it is currently
being tested and so the first example
here is the an attorney from the Orange
County Public Defender's Office reached
out to the southern Coalition
and she had a client who was arrested
with a large amount of narcotics in his
truck but the story of how they were
stopped and searched was a little
unclear and the attorney notice that if
she sees these two particular officers
more frequently when she's representing
Hispanic defendants and so after some
back and forth with the judge he got a
court order to release the officer IDs
and they plugged it in the website and
what they found is that these two
officers accounted for sixty percent of
all the Hispanic searches in that County
for the previous decade and this is an
accounting whose population is only
about eight percent Hispanic you can see
the census data there for Orange County
North Carolina alright so I will try to
do a little quick game out here and so
when you pull up the the site you get to
see the two states that we can only have
of North Carolina and in Maryland and
you can drill in and when you get to the
estate home page you're presented with
some options to drill into like the
various agencies but also to you can
click on find a stop and search for four
stops there so for here what we're just
going to look for the orange county
sheriff since you can type it in and
bring up the the first primary feature
of the site which I talked about earlier
is the officer dashboard and you can
sort of scroll through hearing we you
know we have stopped percentages by race
and ethnicity all the way down to search
percentages and contraband hit rate so
it's all this data over time and you can
kind of browse through and look at it
and I do want to note that there's this
toggle up at the top which allows you to
switch between race and ethnicity
obviously do these are they're different
they're recorded differently we can't do
like a black to white to Hispanic driver
comparison because theyre it's just how
it's a factor of how they're recorded so
we can flip back and forth here to sort
of look at the data slice in a different
way but yeah so if we just look at the
top level
you know it's not on par but it's fairly
close it looks like they stop around ten
percent ten percent of the driver
stopped or Hispanic and so it's kind of
in the ballpark of what the demographic
makeup of that that county is and but if
we scroll down and look at the
departmental search wait it is it is
fairly high especially when we're
considering like the average North
Carolina officers searches around three
percent so here we can see in 2010 that
they were searching twenty-three percent
of Hispanic driver so it's kind of like
a high high number and something we kind
of want to drill into and look at and so
what we can do is come up and click on
on find a stop up here and it presents
us with a forum where we can drill into
the data and look at it so we can type
in the Orange County Sheriff's Office
enter this officer idea that we're we're
going to look at and we get the results
of the search results for all this
officer over time all their stops so
this is that second primary feature that
allows you to and a drill in and look at
look at the data if you click on the
officer ID will be able to see the
officer dashboard and so yeah so if we
look at this officer it's pretty
interesting you can sort of see there
are some really high search rates but
still you know still way above the
average even later on down here in 2010
and and if we just look at searches you
can see that for you know several years
on end they were searching more Spanish
drivers than non-hispanic drivers and
again this is in a county that's only
eight percent Hispanic so the public
defender took this data back to the
judge and eventually the man who was
facing life in prison that was offered a
plea deal obviously the point here isn't
that we should use this technology to
help criminals get away but the reality
is that in order to sort of change this
policing culture and promote equitable
policing that a database approach can be
really powerful this was the largest
drug arrest in the county for that year
and it was a big deal when it got thrown
out and it affects a lot of people even
the police chief and when it likely
could have been mitigated earlier on and
you know I think in this case the the
data transparency kind of identified an
issue from outside the department like
it wasn't you know it wasn't seen early
on but this allowed like the public
defender to kind of look at it and sort
of say something something that doesn't
look right so it's nice for the to have
that accessibility to the data and so
ideally if this happens enough more
people will see the the value of this
data before I talk on or touch on the
next target audience I do want to talk
about a little bit about using this data
responsibly we do stress that everyone
should kind of be mindful of how they
they use the data it doesn't always tell
the whole the whole picture and we only
sort of analyze it and they're in
certain ways you don't want to just say
oh well like ninety percent of this
officer stops or black or Hispanic
drivers because you kind of want to know
more about more about that officer where
there a sign that you know they could be
assigned in a neighborhood with that
demographic characteristic and
unfortunately we don't have and in the
statewide data set we don't have any
more granular locational data we just
know that an agency made a stop we don't
have like a street address or Latin long
so we can't mash it up with like police
beats or anything like that but so yeah
so the idea isn't for an attorney to
just like print up the website and use
it without additional research and we're
also kind of intentional on how we
display the data we're not trying to
like rank agencies or offer ask or
anything we're kind of just presenting
that the data as is another part of the
site is for police management this is a
fayetteville police chief chief Medlock
and this kind of ties back to the data
not being reviewed for over ten years
you know police agencies themselves
weren't really looking at the data they
were just kind of like record it report
it and send it up the state and
Medlock's idea is to use this
as a diagnostic tool so they you know
Chief can log on and see what their
department looks like see what and go
and look at individual officers there
are no names on the website those are
protected by by law and you know to get
from name or from ID to name you have to
have a court order so that that's all
protected but the Chiefs that you know
they know their officer IDs and they
also know where their officers are
assigned so that they have a good like
insight into this and so they can like
instantly see the career enforcement
history for for their officers and and
like bring this up an annual performance
reviews and look at it generally the
idea around this is fairly mixed Ian
showed this this tool at a White House
event and in in a room that's full of
like a lot of big city chiefs and the
room was pretty divided about half and
half I think there are a lot of the
opinions out there like the value of
having this data be accessible to the to
the public but i think that there's
likes growing realization that this is
kind of the future and that it's you
know being more transparent is that that
builds trust and so i want to show off
another feature by looking at the
fayetteville data can find it so yeah
medlock was brought on in the wake of a
profiling related scandal at the end of
2012 and he noticed that that most
traffic stops were low-level technical
type stops in fact this is kind of
common across most agencies that the
smaller the technical offense there's
like more discretion is exercised by the
officer and so you can see you can see
if we sort of look here no for all
Fayetteville is going down which is nice
especially after a Fayetteville after
cheap Medlock joined the force and what
he kind of noticed is in this graph we
like to talk about a lot so that this is
these are all of these bars here are
kind of in this example in comparison to
white drivers so this example is all
black versus white drivers here and so
it he notices that
for an example with a DWI there's
there's little or no disparity because
there's there's always like objective
evidence I take a breathalyzer they're
serving all over the river something but
like for a seat belt violation
historically in Fayetteville black
drivers have been 110% more likely in
the course of a seatbelt stop to be
searched and and so you know it's like a
pretty big disparity and and again the
question is kind of like well if if they
are seeing these disparities like are
they actually finding more or contraband
in the end and and the answer is usually
no you can see here they're pretty close
so the contraband hit rates right around
twenty twenty-five percent when in fact
Frank and SES J kind of review this data
over the past ten years and it found
almost no difference it's about a
19-percent hit rate across both black
and white drivers and yet you know black
drivers we usually being searched more
often so yeah that was an overview of
how to how the site is currently being
used and I'll talk a little bit now
about how the site works and is a high
level over oh I'll be useful if I turn
line yeah this is a high level overview
of the site architecture you can sort of
see we have the browser on the side all
the way back to our database and and so
yeah the front end is a mix of Django
and JavaScript with d3 for the
visualizations and backbone to kind of
communicate with our API and we have a
django app that stores all of our our
business logic including the modeling
for the data and then an API that
aggravates at all and it's all stored in
our postgresql database and so again we
have all reported traffic stops that's a
100 counties in North Carolina 314
agencies everything from the State
Highway Patrol all the way down to like
a University Police Department they have
over 20 million stops and nearly half of
those are for the State Highway Patrol
here you can see a high-level snapshot
of the the schema of the data that we
have so we have like the agency and ID
again it's it's anonymous it's not even
their badge number it's just an ID that
they use for reporting and when the when
the stop happened the purpose of the
stop if what what type of action was
taken for every stop there are one or
more related people so you could have a
driver and or a passenger in the car and
and and then that table contains their
demographic information so they're their
age their gender race ethnicity and then
if a search we have some search data to
if there's a search happen then we have
some information on that as well and so
we we get all this data from the state
it's obtained via regular FOIA request
and they they sent a CD which with when
it's uncompressed it's about five
gigabytes of tabular data it's all
stored in a Microsoft sequel server on
their end so we know that they kind of
centrally maintain the data which is not
something we're certain about Maryland
which I'll talk about and it's the full
data set each time we're not receiving
like just since we last made the request
and so what we do is we just store it on
s3 and import it using our ETL process
so it's a large data set we don't really
know what change like maybe there was a
an agency that was behind in reporting
that happens a lot we do it every month
and they may not report it for a couple
months and so we don't want to like miss
anything or if somebody updated a row
that we wouldn't want to miss that and
so it's easier for us just to kind of
reinforce the whole the whole data set
each time we get it and so this this ETL
process is designed to be you know kind
of atomic and repeatable so what we do
is we just download the latest data we
do some cleaning which in North Carolina
we don't really do anything we just
convert it to CSV and and imported in
the database we know we can't really use
anything like Django's bulk inserts here
because we be instantiating like 40
million objects and it's not really that
efficient and so we just convert it to
CSV and use postgres is a copy command
to load it into the database you can see
here on
we get it in it's all within a single
transaction so we just truncate all the
tables that are there run the copy
command add the constraints back and
indexes back and then commit it just
it's kind of nice if anything fails it
just automatically rolls back and
website has all the old data that we had
before so yeah we have 40 million rows
about across both the stops and the
people tables and searches the entire
process runs in about 30 minutes a lot
of that time is just kind of unzipping
it and converting it CSV but there's
also a lot a lot of time in the database
as well but once we get rid of the
indexes our inserts are relatively fast
we can get about 21 million in and 88
seconds and this was an early scaling
issue for us you know it's not the
largest data set ever we don't really
need massive scaling for for this site
but some it was kind of fairly sizable
for our little team and we were trying
to figure out how to make this this work
and especially when you're running this
on like a small ec2 instance on a budget
the imports would kind of end up taking
hours and so that's why we did this
method of dropping all the constraints
and indexes to to make it go faster and
so all this data now is loaded into its
own Postgres database because we wanted
to think about how to sort of plan for
the future and add more and more sites
and so we we're adding Maryland right
now and you know this means not only
updating the design and the UX of the
site but also being able to model it
differently as well so each each state
has its own python and django app and we
chose to sort of normalize the data at
the api level so the the graphs and the
backbone code kind of all expect the
same general schema via the API but
behind the scenes the data it can look a
little bit different and this is nice
because we this will allow the sites to
have some extra features where
fayetteville provided some geolocation
all data and so we're looking to add
that that type of data to the north
north carolina site a lot of yes a lot
of cactuses work was sort of in this
abstraction piece here and trying to
make it easier to extend in custom
and we use Django's a database routing
to kind of like figure out which which
database we should talk to you based on
the type of requests that we're making
and currently this all just runs on a
single link to box in the cloud and but
it could easily be kind of be split up
down the road if we ever need that type
of distribution and so now we have this
Maryland app but the Maryland data is a
different story it turned out to be very
different and far less accessible and it
took me in a really long time to get a
working working copy of the data kind of
amazed how easy it is in North Carolina
and so basically we would get different
dumps every couple of months and they
would be different they would just leave
would have like no officer IDs or no
agency names and so it was really hard
to figure out like what what we were
working with or what they were sending
us and and it wasn't normalized at all
like it was in North Carolina he was one
of the data dumps that we had it's kind
of like spread across like all these
different Excel files in different years
and the years would have liked
drastically different numbers of
agencies in them and in in these files
themselves there would be vastly
different reporting format so it was you
know I don't know maybe they don't
centrally collected and analyzed we
don't we don't really know why it it was
this way maybe they're just giving us
the raw data for the officers and the
agency's report up to the state but it
just simply wasn't as easy for us to get
it in finally we got three years of data
still took a lot of cleaning to get to
get it to work even down to like the
time field you could tell it was kind of
hand entered in or even when it was
transcribed we just have times that that
made no sense or that was just across to
all the field so a lot of cleaning was
involved and and 11 yeah one area we're
like in North Carolina we have these
stop reasons that are kind of
categorized for us like a seatbelt
violation or vehicle regulatory
violation but in Maryland we actually
got the individual
code number which is actually kind of
interesting you can really it's very
detailed you can see ya like that so the
codes are on the side here 13 6 07 e
which is great but if again if the
officers kind of filling this in by hand
there's just like tons of errors that
that happened and so what we would do is
just kind of clean it up with some
regular expressions and then map them
into into categories and we didn't do
this the subject coalition did they
reviewed the statute in the law and we'd
provide them a CSV file and they would
just sort of map up the statutes to the
categories and get everything
appropriately organized that's the CSV
file there by the way all this code is
open source on github which I'll have a
link to at the end we also did this with
agency names Maryland didn't give us any
names we'd had a bunch of agency codes
which were hard to decode and and and
then we also wanted to introduce this
idea to provide a sort of reference
demographic information from the Census
and you know it's not always clear to
sort of pair the agencies to a
particular census ID you know it's kind
of easy to match Aberdeen police
department with the city of Aberdeen in
the census but you know cities within
counties can have like why widely
varying demographics and and when you're
looking at the census the county
demographics include the cities and so
you can't always accurately pair like a
County Sheriff with the county
demographics because the you know those
demographics may be heavily weighted by
the city where the sheriff doesn't
usually police in but you can in some
counties and so again the southern
Coalition kind of looked at this and
picked out IDs that we have a census we
just like paying the census API and pull
in all the data and then they match it
up with the the census ID so i wanted to
show a little bit about our our API
okay so this is Montgomery County in in
Maryland and if you come up here and
just look at our you are URL it's an
agency of ID with 80 there if we just
add API to the URL you can see we get
our sort of API browser and see the data
that's returned and includes the census
data that we were talking about you had
stops to the end of that URL we get all
the stops aggregated by by year for the
by race and ethnicity in in Maryland
they they reported differently Hispanic
drivers are just reported alongside
black and white so you can see it mixed
in here and so yes this is what d3 uses
to draw these these graphs and you know
they're not really complex aggregates
they're fairly simple to do but given
the data set size and like with the
State Highway Patrol it's 10 million
stops being you know aggregated when
they click on the page and so it's it's
intensive for that brief moment can be
kind of time consuming luckily for us
it's all read only get it never changes
once we import it so we can just kind of
heavily cash it not really up to to
worry about that use a django cash
machine for that so yeah maryland is a
is a much smaller data set we only have
three years so far the southern
Coalition is still kind of analyzing it
with us and we only have about two
million stops and we weren't able to
normalize all the stops we just had some
bad data that we didn't really know how
to to deal with and so we had to discard
about 1% of it but the the biggest
discovery that we ran into is that
Baltimore wasn't really following both
the law and I shouldn't think of my area
yeah so we we saw that Baltimore data
was in the the data set but it was
missing a lot of fields here you can see
a sort of it's kind of small on the
screen but it's all boss Baltimore
police depart
because there's a lot of empty cells
we're missing a ton of data including
the date and whether or not there was a
search who was the officer and and they
give a lot of it you know sort of some
excuses around it just like there was no
data there was a crop server I think man
Maryland's structured a little bit
differently that they aren't required to
report it some years and so some
agencies has choose not to report it so
we didn't have data for 2014 and 2015
apparently and and so Ian actually took
this data back to to Maryland and just
this week Baltimore kind of admitted to
this fault and so I think they're going
to plan to figure figure that out
together and so yeah that that was a
pretty interesting discovery and lastly
I wanted to give a quick overview of
just the it's a fairly simple data set
but I wanted to sort of show you what
what we did to I get the officer or the
departmental search rates and so I kind
of pre-loaded some data here from our
clean data from Maryland and so we look
at the data types in this this data
frame you can see we have like the time
and agency name and these this is all
stop data so the dry and it's all driver
data in Maryland so that we have looked
with age race and ethnicity of the
driver whether or not a search was
conducted so you kind of kick it the the
data here and see that these are the
different agencies whether or not search
was conducted here to stop reason those
those codes that we cleaned up see we
have about 22 million stops in this data
set and if we just look at them sort of
grouped by the agencies you can see with
the Maryland State Police is the largest
and Montgomery has about 200 27,000 so I
wanted to drill in here to Montgomery
County so we just filter down by the
agency description is all in pandas and
make a new data frame just for for
Montgomery and then we want a sort of
aggregate
this information by the year and the
agent beer in the race and so we're
going to use the date time in the year
there and the ethnicity which is the
name of a column here and so we'll do a
group by and pandas and do a count on
those and then we get this this
aggregated data frame back of like in
2013 there were six around almost 17,000
black drivers were stopped and we want
to compare this to the searches and so
what we can do is this look for where
search camp was conducted and do the
same kind of grouping and we'll get all
of our our searches here obviously
smaller numbers and in order to compare
them we want to merge the data frames
together so we combine them using this
merge command and get them all and merge
them on where the daytime and the
ethnicity fields matched and then we
need to get the search rate so we just
take all the the searches that we have
and / the stops x 100 and we get a rate
the departmental search raid by by year
basically we can pivot this table so
that our columns are the races the dates
or the rows and then it makes it
relatively easy to to plot this on on
the map on the graph and so that's how
that's how we r you know bait more or
less doing it in in sequel but this is a
visual example here Jupiter and that is
the whole talk thanks for coming out the
code is online there on github open data
policing NC and yeah any questions
he obviously mentioned Maryland but I
was curious if you could talk about
other states that either you know have
laws in effect to collect the sort of
information or other you know efforts
that are similar to this to try to
publish the information yeah there are
only a handful of states that do it you
know that Rhode Island and Connecticut
and we recently just received the data
set for Illinois which were kind of
excited about because it at Chicago in
it but I think that's really about it I
know that California just enacted one
last year but so it'll take a while to
get many any kind of longitudinal data
for that but there are only a handful of
states in the country that do it okay so
this just goes to the underlying quality
of the data um you're the racial and
ethnicity data are being self reported
by the officer correct it's great um in
a way it occurs to me that you may be
lucky that no one's looked at this data
for ten years because your self
reporting hasn't been influenced by
results so my question is is there some
kind of cross validation that you could
do to ensure that the that the
self-reporting matches with the actual
race or ethnicity of the individuals for
example if someone is charged with a
crime you probably could go back and get
that data and is that in the works or is
that something you've thought about
that's a good question yeah it's not
really a something that's going to be a
feature on the website obviously if if
you were stopped you can kind of search
yourself like you could look for say
that this agency stopped me drill it
down to a particular day and kind of see
how they they reported you but like you
were saying yeah like if a public
defender or an attorney is kind of
looking at this data more frequently
than they would be able to kind of
compare that to we don't really have a
way to like do that holistically across
the data set obviously but I think it's
an important or an interesting idea so
then you said that contraband heat rate
was not different in four different
races what was it percent off
um between the races you said that it
was 25 around twenty-five percent for
each race what it was twenty-five
percent off oh oh sorry so yeah so like
the SC SJ when they looked at that
historically over ten years they found
that the contraband hit rates were about
equal and I was but I think that was
about nineteen percent of the of the
drivers that they searched had
contraband and that was equal between
black and white drivers vanity if its
twenty five percent for each car that
was searched and they searched some
races more than others isn't it that
actually there is some serving balance
um I don't know if I understand the
question what do you mean so take it
offline sorry I we're gonna have to do a
quick room change so we have five
minutes until the next talk starts
thanks